Do you think the European Union is worth it or should we end it?
Many people feel a strong disconnect with the EU while others praise it's
achievements.
Everything considered is its existence good or bad.
For Europeans,
since it looks like the UK is leaving,
the EU will mostly treated as if it's no longer part of the club.
The European Union combining it's 27 member countries has a population of about
450 million people making it the third most populous sort of country in the
world.
It's the world's second largest economy by GDP and has the biggest single market
in the world,
but originally the creation of the European Union was all about one thing.
Pace.
Europeans are really good at war,
so they were embroiled in bloody conflicts for basically all their history.
A century long rivalry between Germany and France alone cost millions of lives
and ran so deeply.
The Germans invented their own word for it.
App Find Shafts.
After the Second World War,
Europeans decided they wanted lasting peace.
That was not based on a balance of military power.
Instead,
the economies politics and people's of Europe should become so closely
interconnected that war would become both impractical and unthinkable.
The plan works between EU members.
We've had over 70 years of peace.
Okay,
piece is great and all,
but what are the European Union's achievements and problems today?
EU citizens benefit from many individual freedoms.
EU treaties and regulations ensure easy travel,
cheap telecommunications,
a great variety of goods and services as well as very strong health and safety
standards.
European institutions are not afraid to pick a fight with companies such as
Microsoft,
apple or Facebook about fair competition,
tax evasion or data protection.
Through the EU science programs,
the European countries became a collaborative engine that serves as a hub of
science and the wider world unrestricted travel and the right to work anywhere.
It makes it easy to apply for funds and set up international teams of experts
with the best equipment and turn the EU became the world leader in terms of its
global share of science researchers and produces more than 25% of the world's
research output with only 5% of its population,
but many citizens feel distrust towards the EU.
Brussels seems far away and untransparent technocratic and difficult to
understand.
It doesn't help that the EU is terrible at outreach and expanding what it
actually does.
This disconnect has also led to an ever shrinking voter turn out to over the
decades more transparency and accountability are desperately needed if the EU
institutions want the trust of their citizens.
Currently the EU is still shaken by the refugee crisis of 2015 some countries
have accepted far greater numbers of asylum seekers than others.
While the border countries are overwhelmed and feel left alone,
other countries are shocked by the initially unregulated mass immigration and
closed their borders effectively shutting down the largest root into Europe.
The [inaudible] wealth and freedom make it an attractive destination and this is
unlikely to change.
The population is split on how to react to that.
Some argue that Europe let in too many immigrants with a different culture
without strictly demanding integration.
While others argue that immigration is not the problem,
but that racism and discrimination of immigrants is preventing integration to
strike a balance between helping refugees,
turning illegal immigrants away and successfully integrating the ones that stay
remains one of the most difficult and controversial challenges of the Union.
Immigration aside,
many more challenges lie in the future like defense.
Traditionally,
European countries have relied strongly on the protection of the u s through
NATO,
but in the current political climate,
Europe has to ask itself if it really wants to depend on the United States for
its safety.
If combined today,
the militaries of EU members can form an effective defensive force and be the
third largest military in the world,
that could save a lot of money,
safeguard or European borders and enhance cultural understanding with soldiers
from 27 different countries serving one common purpose.
What about money?
Well,
it's complicated.
The EU created the largest single market in the world in site is you can trade
border and customs free countries that entered it got a massive boost to their
economists,
even between neighbors trade increased by up to 500% and there was a steady
creation of new jobs.
Research has suggested that joining the EU has left most new members with an
average of eight 12% higher GDP than if they had remained outside and for those
regions with a weaker economies and poor infrastructure,
EU institutions provide a billions of euros every year helping economic
investment infrastructure and social development.
On the negative side,
the EU tries to hold together countries with vastly different economies and laws
regarding labor,
taxes and social security.
The cost of one hour of work in an EU country ranges from four euros an hour to
40 euros an hour.
Some countries have large industries and strong exports while others focus on
services,
tourism,
more natural resources.
On top of this,
the euro is the common currency of some,
but not all of these countries.
As the crisis shows,
this can be a recipe for disaster.
You cannot unify a vastly different economists under one currency,
but leave that economic policy is separate.
So should all EU countries unite under the common currency or not?
Should the weakest links be thrown out of the euro or should countries be made
to adopt a common policies on taxes,
healthcare and social security?
It's a question that's been brewing for years and there's nowhere near a
solution.
So everything briefly considered is the European Union worth it?
Here is our answer.
The EU is very flawed and still needs a lot of work,
but it's fair to say that the European Union makes Europeans powerful in the
world.
Put together,
we lead in science.
What are the strongest economic powers could have one of the strongest
militaries in the world,
but more importantly,
the EU gives us peace,
security and a sense of shad identity and something we all crave in these
turbulent times.
Stability if we want to protect the values were so proud of a strong European
Union is the best way to make sure our voice is heard in the world alone as
small states will hardly stand a chance.
In a world of shifting superpowers,
what do you think about the EU when its future?
In recent years,
the discussion about political topics has become super toxic with sad real world
consequences.
Let's not do that.
If you don't agree with this video,
you're not our enemy.
You just have a different opinion and that's fine.
We're all in the same boat after all.
So let's have a fact based discussion about our future.